[Music]
This is I'd like to know, a Bible
question and answer program that it is
our privilege and pleasure to bring to
you each and every day. Thank you for
joining us and sharing part of your no
doubt busy day with us. My name is CA
Murray. I'm in the company of Pastor
Steven Boore, president and founder of
the ministry. Pastor, always good to
have you here.
>> A blessing to participate in this
program.
>> And Pastor David Saladar, the general
manager of our Latino network. David,
always good to have you here also.
>> Thank you, pastor. It's always an honor
for me to work with you and Pastor
Boore.
>> And it is also good to answer your
questions, something that we love to do.
If you want to get in on the fun, we
encourage you to do so by writing to us
at tvsumtv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org.
og and we will get to your questions
just as soon as we can. If you don't
hear them the first week after you send
them, believe me, we're coming to them.
We've got a pretty good stack of
questions, which is a a privilege to
have and we will answer your questions.
We will get to them. We make this
promise. Pastor Salazar, would you lead
us in prayer and then we will launch out
to our first question.
>> Absolutely. Let's pray. Heavenly Father,
we thank you Lord for giving us another
opportunity to share from your word the
things that you have given to us to
understand and to be able to uh explain
in the light of what you have revealed
through your word and through the
writings of Ellen White. We pray that
you will give us wisdom, understanding.
We don't have in our own selves the the
knowledge of all things, but through our
submission to your will and through the
influence of the Holy Spirit, we know
that we can understand better the
scriptures. And we pray that you will
help us to be channels of light of
wisdom to those who are watching that
they may be able to receive the word
that this comes from you and be closer
to you and understand your word better.
We pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question comes
to us again from Malawi. We had a a
question from Malawi just a couple of
programs ago. This one is from Felix. Um
help me understand this verse. It is 1
Peter 3 18- 20 and then chapter 4 verse
6. Does it mean when Jesus died, he went
and preached to the spirits of the dead
uh who had died during the flood in
Noah's time? This is the second time
we've gotten a question sort of similar
to this. It comes up periodically
because it is something that people want
to know about. Again, my pastor, my
friend, it gives us the opportunity to
promo your book on uh state of the dead
because a lot of these things are
wrestled with are addressed and
redressed in that particular book. Uh so
before we answer the question, tell us
what's in there contentwise and how it
appertains to this particular question.
Well, I consider this to be one of the
most important study notes that I've
ever prepared here at Secrets Unsealed
because we know that the two errors that
Satan is going to promote at the end of
time are Sunday as the day of rest
>> and also the idea that the dead can come
back and communicate with the living.
>> Uh a few years ago, I prepared these
study notes. The title of it is
misinterpreted texts on the state of the
dead. Mhm.
>> And basically uh here I deal with the
text that people use to try and prove
that when a person dies, their soul
leaves the body to go to a different
place. I'll just read the titles of some
of the uh chapters. Um Rachel's
departing soul,
>> a thief and a witch, absent from the
body and present with the Lord, the
souls under the altar. And lo and
behold, on page 99 of these study notes,
there's a chapter that's titled um the
spirits, preaching to the spirits in
prison.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Uh it's a whole chapter uh probably
about 14 15 pages where I study this
particular passage in 1 Peter chapter 3
18 to 22 and also include chapter 4 and
verse 6. M
>> um so I don't know how much time we want
to dedicate here in the program because
you'd have to do an ex Jesus of this
passage very carefully the words and the
syntax and the grammar and so on it
becomes very technical. Um the uh Felix,
if you're watching this program, I would
encourage you to either acquire a copy
of my study notes here at Secrets
Unsealed, uh a hard copy. Uh if not, you
can always go to our app. Our app uh is
free. You can download it, our Sum TV
app, and uh there you can uh read all of
the notes that we've ever prepared uh
for free online. So if you want the full
story, I would suggest that you uh get
the study notes uh either electronically
or in hard copy form.
>> Yeah. And I think that's that's why I I
sort of pitched it to you because this
is a subject that can get a little
wonky, you know, it it can kind of you
can dive in and don't come up for
>> quite a little while, you know, because
you've got to you've got to walk through
sequentially and you've got to you got
to really take your time to understand
it because of the massive
misinterpretation. And and when we say
that, we're not we're not uh belittling
anybody. Sometimes people have poor
exeetical skills. Sometimes their their
is just not as it should be. And when
you start wrong, you stay wrong and you
don't always come out right. Uh which is
why you've got to walk through a spoon.
It's like eating an elephant, you know,
spoonful at a time. You can't just try
to take it all. Uh so I think your
counselor is very very good, pastor. Um
get the notes and you can get them
online. So uh if this is an issue
because we have answered this we've
taken almost a full program to do so uh
and to do it justice we'd have to do it
again full program so get the notes and
and that will help you plus you can have
you can make notes on the notes so that
you can understand it fully
>> okay I think uh that would be a good
recommendation because we have done a
full program on this before in our Q&A
program yes
>> and also we have done this one on DV D
in the series on the state of the dead
besides being written here in the notes.
>> Yeah, it's very difficult to take
shortcuts with this with this particular
issue. Uh
so we thank you for that. Let's go now
to let's see is it Kathy Kath M writing
to us from Florida. pastors.
In an SDA devotional I use by William
Johnson, he states on page 162 that
nowhere in the New Testament do we find
an abrogation of the ceremonial laws. He
goes on to say that Christians don't
deserve them
>> don't observe
>> oh I'm sorry oh don't observe them um
before Christ. Is that BC?
>> I think so. of of Jesus purity which
cannot take on defilement.
I was reminded of Col Colossians 2:14. I
know where that's coming from regarding
the handwriting of ordinances that was
against us, nailing it to his cross.
Some have believed the moral ten
commandment law was nailed there. We
know that's incorrect. Others have
stated that our sin was nailed there.
true since Jesus became sin for us.
However, how do we reconcile these
differing stances with Johnson's
statement? Thank you for your insight on
this tough topic.
William Johnson was was the editor of
>> the review for many years.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> All right. uh not having his page 162
statement before us. Let's just deal
with the doctrine per se and and and not
try to correct whatever he has. Let's
just give the truth about the doctrine.
All right. Um Pastor David, do you want
to start? Well, yeah, I could say, well,
in Colossians verse 14, chapter 2:14,
um, the verse that she's referring to,
it says, "Having wiped out the
handwriting of requirements that was
against us, which was contrary to us,
and he has taken it out of the way,
having nailed it to the cross." Now this
verse is an important verse because it
speaks of some of the requirements that
were made handwritten as he said there
in the past. Now we know that this is in
reference to certain ceremonials is
particularly speaking in the
circumcision because this is what verse
11 is speaking of is speaking of
circumcision and how Christ uh basically
his his experience his life uh takes
away that requirement or his he's his
dead in the cross takes away the
requirement. So in some ways this verse
is used to support the idea that
ceremonial laws were nailed on the
cross. uh now the particular statement
that William Johnson says which I
haven't read this devotional by the way
so I have no idea exactly uh you know
what he's coming from but I think it's
it's somewhat
you know his position might be to a
certain degree true in the sense that we
don't have a particular expression where
it says you know don't keep the feast
days you know in the New Testament where
where we see from the word of God saying
that you know that the Passover is done
away with that the uh uh feast of the uh
the trumpets or all these things are
done away with. We don't have
particularly those words in in in a in a
sense. However, we have to remember that
the things that were given to the to the
to the Jewish nation to the Hebrews as
ceremonial were all pointing to Christ.
They were fulfilling. They were they
were an illustration, a practical way,
an experimental way so people could see
what it meant to plan salvation. And so
as we understand that Christ fulfilled
these
these ceremonial ceremonies, these
ordinances,
we can be certain that
the ceremony, the ceremonial laws have
already been fulfilled in Jesus.
That is when you understand when you
study each ceremony, each feast day is
each uh one of these things, we can see
how they were fulfilling Jesus. But you
have to take a step back and really be
open to the concept of what that feast
or what ceremonial thing was meant to be
and how Jesus fulfilled that individual
aspect. Now uh and this is now uh the
experience that we have to have. Christ
fulfilled those ceremonies but have
nothing to do with the ten commandments.
They're two different things. One points
to a part of his ministry, a part of his
work, his life. Another points or the
law of God. It's a perpetual experience
because it reflects the character of God
in giving us the ordinances to love the
Lord and love our neighbor. So the two
are never the same. They're two
different things. one fulfilled in
Christ, the other one continues on
throughout eternity.
>> The Greek word that is used here for
handwriting of of ordinances is the
Greek word kerograph
which in the ancient world was used for
a bond of debt. In other words, a person
signed an IOU and then would have to pay
for that. Mhm.
>> Now the entire ceremonial system was an
IOU system.
>> Yes. Very good.
>> Because because the entire system could
not really solve the sin problem.
>> And that's what Hebrews is written for
to tell them to assure that
>> it could not it could not take away sin.
The blood of bulls and goats cannot take
away sin. That's 1 Corinthians chap
first Hebrews chapter 10 and verse one.
Mhm.
>> Uh in fact in chapter nine of Hebrews
you have a contrast between the old
system
>> and the new testament system says the
old testament system had to do with
washings and it had to do with
sacrifices and offerings and so on. But
the new system actually takes care of
the problem of the ious. So for example,
anytime an Israelite repented, confessed
their sin on the head of the animal, and
the blood was transferred to the
sanctuary.
Basically, he was transferring in an
>> IOU
>> into the holy place of the sanctuary
saying somebody's going to pay.
>> Yeah.
>> Jesus is going to pay for that debt ban.
That's what the the handwriting of
ordinances is. It's a debt ban bond. And
so what happens when Jesus comes, he
actually by dying on the cross,
fulfilling everything that the Old
Testament system pointed to, now he
cancels the debt bond for all of those
who in the Old Testament by faith
depending on what he depended on what he
was going to do,
>> correct?
>> But their sins have not been legally
taken care of. Uh in Romans chapter 3 uh
you have a reference to this. Uh Romans
chapter 3 and verse 23 says, "For all
have sinned and fall short of the glory
of God."
>> "Being justified freely by his grace
through the redemption that is in Christ
Jesus, whom God sent forth as a
propitiation by his blood through
faith."
>> Now here comes the key portion. to
demonstrate his righteousness because in
his forbearance God had passed over the
sins that were previously committed.
>> Yes.
>> And we can take the example of Moses for
example.
>> You know Moses was taken to heaven
before the death of Christ.
>> Yeah. So what would have happened if
Christ had not come to pay the IOU that
Moses had because Moses undoubtedly
repented and you know he sacrificed an
animal. Uh what would have happened to
Moses if Christ had not come to die?
>> Notice he would have had to get a return
ticket.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Because it was one way,
>> right? Yeah. But because because the old
system only pointed forward to the
solution for sin,
>> it did not actually take away the sin.
>> Well said. Well said. Um Moses and
Elijah.
>> Yeah.
>> Christ fair would be their eviction
notice. They had to come out. It had to
come out. Um
>> just quickly to to add another little
nuance. If we look at Deuteron, you
know, when when you talk about law,
you've got to you've got to nail the
person down. What law are you talking
about? You're talking about the moral
law. You're talking about the ceremonial
law because there are two different
entities placed in two different parts
of the parts of the ark. One under the
mercy seat, other in the side of the
ark. I'm looking at Deuteronomy 31:26.
Take this book of the law and put it
beside the ark of the covenant of the
Lord your God that it may be there as a
witness against you. So here is that
same terminology, witness against you.
So what was canceled? The witness
against you. So you look at the
linguistic similarities and you get a
little clarity on that. So when someone
says, "Well, keep the law. Some was
nailed to the cross." What was nailed to
the cross? Certainly not the moral law.
That's once and forever written in
stone. This other thing witnessed
against you. That was what stopped as
you well said it. It was a it was
looking forward to the fact that Christ
is going to pay that debt.
um that debt could not be paid by man.
It could not be paid by angels. Christ
had to pay it. And once he paid it, the
debt was paid. Paid once and for all.
And that's why the book of Hebrews is
written because uh Hebrew Christians
were thinking about going back into
Judaism and saying, "Well, maybe we
ought to know Christ has taken care of
that." Um and keep on going forward
because if you go back, then there's no
there's no redress for your sins. Uh so
well said, pastor. One of the key words
in the book of Hebrews is the word
better.
>> Mhm. Yes. And it's used over and over
again.
>> It the contrast is not that the old
system was bad and the new system is
good. No, no, no. The old system was
good.
>> Mhm.
>> Because it pointed to Christ.
>> Amen.
>> The new system is better because it's a
fulfillment of what pointed forward to
Christ.
>> Amen. Amen. Amen. Well said. Let's see
if we can't slip in one other. Unless
you have something else, pastor, you
want to add or
>> No, no. I think it's just Elg White
mentions uh in regards to when Jesus was
to be crucified and uh we know that at
at the end of his crucifixion, the veil
was split in half. And Sister White
makes a comment in regards to that
symbolized that the ceremonial system
had concluded. Christ became the lamb
that was, you know, slain for humanity.
As pastor Bor mentioned, he paid the
price for our sins. He fixed the IOU
system that we uh had before. So uh even
though biblically there is um perhaps
not does say clearly indicated, the fact
that the Bible does mention that this
the veil was cut in half indicates
clearly that the ceremonial system had
ceased to be effective no longer was
necessary. So I kind of disagree in a
sense to the statement where it says
nowhere in New Testament. I think that
explicitly it's not said but there is
the signs there are enough signs there
in this new testament that says the
ceremonial system was done not the law
of God of course but the ceremonial
system was done away with
>> in fairness to William Johnson who by
the way I took two classes at the
seminary with him. I took the book of
Hebrews, theology of Hebrews, and then I
took Greek exuges Jesus of Hebrews.
>> Um, and uh, he was an excellent teacher,
you know, very softspoken, very, very
good teacher. And uh I always have my
reservations when somebody puts uh that
somebody said something that dot dot dot
which we have in the question.
>> We don't have the context
>> what he's saying
>> for what William Johnson said because uh
I'm not sure that the that the question
is reflecting exactly what William
Johnson believed because I took Hebrews
with him. He clearly believed that the
old system was done away with when
Christ came. Uh maybe he's saying that
there's no text in the New Testament
that explicitly says it.
>> Uh but we don't know the context because
you have dot dot dot after the quotation
that she gives.
>> Correct.
>> And that's why I structured this as I
did because I I wrote articles for for
the for William Johnson. As far as I
know, he was doctrally straight. So
rather than condemn him or try to
determine what he said, let's just tell
the truth about the subject, right? And
then we don't, you know, we're we're on
we're on a safe ground. All righty, four
minutes and change left. Let's go to
Brisbane, Australia. Glenda J writes,
"At the seven second resurrection, LG
White states that at the second
resurrection, the marks of the curse are
visible on all." This reinforces the
idea that the wicked will be raised in
their imperfect earthly condition. There
must be a period of time while Satan
tries to get armies to fight for their
to fight for New Jerusalem. If I come up
in that resurrection, I am bedridden. I
will
>> it will
>> it will uh be torture to lay on the
ground and I think of many people who
died of cancer. Could you give me your
opinion?
Is she conflating or confusing the
second resurrection?
>> I think that she's referring to the
second resurrection because it's talking
about uh Satan getting the armies armies
together to fight the new Jerusalem.
>> And that that's post thousand-year
period, post millennium. Correct. Uh at
the end when when it's going to be going
to be death. That's what was was kind of
throwing my mind.
I think the key the key to this is that
in the last chapter of great
controversy,
>> Ellen White says that when the wicked
resurrect, Satan will strengthen the
weak.
>> Yes.
>> So maybe maybe those who are in
wheelchairs, they're not going to be in
wheelchairs or they're in their bed,
they're not going to be in their bed
because Satan can perform miracles, too.
Mhm.
>> Uh and so uh you know I can understand
that um that Glenda is concerned about
individuals who are bedridden and am I
going to lay on the ground and know what
about people who suffered from cancer.
Uh but you know after the millennium
Satan is going to strengthen the weak.
Those are the words of Ellen White in
the last chapter of great controversy.
And another thing, pastor, I mean, we
have to kind of, you know, we're sort of
what speculating in a way. The Lord has
not really revealed to us what exactly
the the life of these individuals, how
long the time they would have. Uh
remember that the earth is desolate.
It's disarrayed. There is no life in
earth per se. And so there's no real
food available. And so there's you can
you can start speculating a lot of
things how they're going to sustain
themselves, how they're going to live or
whatever, you know, what that period of
time is. We don't know those answers
yet. Uh maybe they don't they wake up
with a you know they do wake up with the
marks of the curse on them and they come
with the same same mindset and the same
uh thoughts and evil thoughts that they
had before. Uh but
as far as their body specifically since
God gives them that life is not Satan
even though he claims it is him. Uh we
don't know exactly how that life is life
form. What type of is body composition
we don't know those things. Those
details are I think too you know maybe
they're kind of kind of blurred for our
own benefit. What we need to make sure
is that we stand in the right path and
that we are actually resurrected in the
first resurrection. so that we can enjoy
the the life of on the new earth and
receive the salvation of God and let
those who are wicked, they'll pay the
penalty. Ultimately, we know that the
destruction of them is going to be by
the lake of fire
>> and they will be judged and receive a a
a punishment according to their deeds.
Therefore, some of them will be in a lot
of time of destruction and some of them
will be destroyed quickly. So we know
that God will be fair in destroying the
wicked but ultimately I think the more
important thing for us is to be faithful
today and to be part of the first
resurrection.
>> Amen.
>> Quickly, you're saying if I come up in
that resurrection, I am bedridden. Uh
Glenn, don't prepare for that
resurrection. Don't even think about
that resurrection. Don't concern
yourself with that resurrection.
>> You work towards the first resurrection.
We know what's going to happen then. We
know how you're going to come up then.
Don't trouble yourself about the second
resurrection because ultimately all of
those people are lost.
>> That's right.
>> So, the Lord has something for them that
you don't want to be a part of. You want
to be a part of the resurrection because
the Lord has something for you that you
do want to be a part of. Amen.
>> And uh we hope we've answered your
question. Thank you for sending it in.
God bless you all. We'll see you again
soon. Bye-bye.
Heat.
[Music]